it has certainly brought opportunities
to me and you know it is a director of
marketing and Communications that is
being offered to me it's anywhere close
to you know 40 to 50 percent uh jump
hi my name is Sanji vishwanathan I'm
based out of Mumbai current designation
is that of an associate director for
marketing and Communications at coaches
of cooperation he discovered that my
true calling is is more on the side of
technology so I joined a you know
mid-sized service provider organization
as a as a market intelligence
competitive intelligence service and
then post that is when like kind of you
know branched out and moved into a role
into analyst relations and buys
relations industrial relations besides
that one other part of the role which I
also do at producer is also look at the
the corporate social responsibility
branding part of the program under
marketing information
primary focus of Enterprises has become
talented so it was it was a no-brainer
in that sense that you know that I had
to look at um you know keeping myself
updated and also you know upskilling
with the right set of you know
Technologies the right set of tools so
during my search is where I Came Upon
post certificate in digital
transformation program in being offered
by simply learn
it has certainly brought opportunities
to me right and I'm currently almost in
the final stages of discussion with a
large uh you know Global service
provider to take up a role which is in
addition to whatever you know has been
my existing
skill set the designation is certainly a
great higher than what what it is
currently so you know it is a director
of marketing and Communications that is
being offered to me right and of course
in terms of the the monetary uh you know
I would say change uh it's anywhere
close to the between a 40 to 50 percent
uh jump the course is certainly added in
order to that aspect of uh you know the
hike that has been offered
the five year old from now should
certainly be when you have to reach a
certain level uh you know in a in a
global organization uh leading
initiatives on digital transformation
per se but given my broader interest in
that sense to you know to really look at
the space of career coaching mentoring
which have also been pursuing I would
like to get associated with
organizations which are adding value to
the society
just one passion of mine of of
approaching mentoring actually kind of
you know keeps me quite occupied even on
the weekends as well when I then you
know interface with a lot of school
students both that you know students who
kind of you know come from pretty good
backgrounds as well as you know who may
not be able to afford that kind of
education right to really help them
understand you know the future and how
can their true strengths be tapped into
to help achieve those objectives besides
that I'm also a trained uh you know
musician so I kind of pursue a
percussion instrument uh as well and I
kind of use the opportunity to maybe you
know participate in in community events
foreign